But one of the clusters we want to show you very quickly
is this amazing cluster of portraits
that we found from museums around the world.
If you could zoom in a little bit more, Cyril.
Just to show you, you can just travel through portraits.
And essentially, you can do nature, you can do horses
and clusters galore.
When we saw all these portraits,
we were like, "Hey, can we do something fun for kids,
or can we do something playful
to get people interested in portraits?"
Because I haven't really seen
young kids really excited to go to a portrait gallery.
I wanted to try to figure something out.
So we created something called the portrait matcher.
It's quite self-explanatory,
so I'm just going to let Cyril show his beautiful face.
And essentially what's happening is, with the movement of his head,
we are matching different portraits around the world from museums.
(Applause)
And I don't know about you,
but I've shown it to my nephew and sister,
and the reaction is just phenomenal.
All they ask me is, "When can we go see this?"
And by the way, if we're nice,
maybe, Cyril, you can smile and find a happy one?
Oh, perfect.
By the way, this is not rehearsed.
Congrats, Cyril. Great stuff. Oh wow.
OK, let's move on; otherwise, this will just take the whole time.
(Applause)
So, art and culture can be fun also, right?
For our last quick experiment --
we call all of these "experiments" --
our last quick experiment comes back to machine learning.
We show you clusters, visual clusters,
but what if we could ask the machine to also name these clusters?
What if it could automatically tag them, using no actual metadata?
So what we have is this kind of explorer,
where we have managed to match, I think, around 4,000 labels.
And we haven't really done anything special here,
just fed the collection.
And we found interesting categories.
We can start with horses, a very straightforward category.
You would expect to see that the machine has put
images of horses, right?
And it has, but you also notice, right over there,
that it has a very abstract image
that it has still managed to recognize and cluster as horses.
We also have an amazing head in terms of a horse.
And each one has the tags as to why it got categorized in this.
So let's move to another one which I found very funny and interesting,
because I don't understand how this category came up.
It's called "Lady in Waiting."
If, Cyril, you do it very quickly,
you will see that we have these amazing images
of ladies, I guess, in waiting or posing.
I don't really understand it.
But I've been trying to ask my museum contacts,
you know, "What is this? What's going on here?"
And it's fascinating.
Coming back to gold very quickly,
I wanted to search for gold
and see how the machine tagged all the gold.
But, actually, it doesn't tag it as gold.
We are living in popular times.
It tags it as "bling-bling."
(Laughter)
I'm being hard on Cyril, because I'm moving too fast.
Essentially, here you have all the bling-bling
of the world's museums organized for you.
And finally, to end this talk and these experiments,
what I hope you feel after this talk is happiness and emotion.
And what would we see when we see happiness?
If we actually look at all the objects
that have been tagged under "happiness,"
you would expect happiness, I guess.
But there was one that came up that was very fascinating and interesting,
which was this artwork by Douglas Coupland,
our friend and artist in residence as well,
called, "I Miss My Pre-Internet Brain."
I don't know why the machine feels like it misses its pre-Internet brain
and it's been tagged here,
but it's a very interesting thought.
I sometimes do miss my pre-Internet brain,
but not when it comes to exploring arts and culture online.
So take out your phones, take out your computers,
go visit museums.
And just a quick call-out to all the amazing archivists,
historians, curators,
who are sitting in museums, preserving all this culture.
And the least we can do is get our daily dose of art and culture
for ourselves and our kids.
Thank you.
(Applause)